I have like a violent amount of makeup
like drugstore to like
very fancy and out of all of them
the best one for my skin tone and like
the most beautiful and natural
and all the ones I go to the most is this Colourpop Blush
stix in cool it
like I have used almost all
this is all that's left
and this is genuinely my favorite blush to this day because it's so like
natural and gives me like the perfect flush for my face and for the longest
like this is for example
another version like
this is great and all
but it's like really pinky so you have to blend it out much more
and I'm very heavy handed right
so this one is like the perfect like
tone for my skin because I don't have to do much of the blending
and I used to buy like the most pigmented
like Pussy Pop pink blush and then like
spend like so long trying to blend into my skin where I was like oh
I can just have something like this is like
more subtle and more appropriate to my skin tone
and then like
I don't do all that work blending
I just tap it out a little bit on the edges and that's it and that's
I'm done anyways
I know again other people have probably realized this
but as someone who's always gone very heavy handed with makeup
because I don't want it to look like I'm not wearing any of that
makes sense like
I want people I won't wanna wear makeup approval to know that I'm wearing makeup
but now I'm like
learning how to do a little bit more subtle makeup
um and I don't know
I just I love this blush
and it's my favorite